[Music]
welcome to rochester new york the home
of kodak eastman situated on lake
ontario and creator of the finest
delicacy in all the land hey can i have
a play with all the garbage on it please
that my friends is the garbage plate and
let me tell you
it is glorious
my name is alex tahu my grandfather
invented the original garbage plate
called hotsome potatoes and my father
perfected the real garbage plate at this
point you're probably wondering what
this so-called garbage plate is i'll
tell you a garbage plate is
let me handle this
garbage plate starts with your choice of
sides from home fries french fries
macaroni salad or beans
and you pick your meat hot dogs
hamburgers cheeseburgers whatever's on
the menu then you add your toppings from
mustard onions and hot sauce ketchup and
red hot is optional then add two pieces
of italian bread and butter and you're
all set to go over the years we've had a
lot of different kind of garbage plates
we actually had our sardine plate years
ago i don't think it could get much
crazier than sardines
[Music]
the best part of this business is of
course the customers without them would
be nothing the place was established to
give people a lot of food at a
reasonable price
for years people have come in here
hungry that didn't have any money my
father always fed them that's really
sweet alex but let's get back to the
garbage because i'm really wondering how
many calories are in a plate i really
don't know some people have said three
thousand i don't think it's that high
but i guess i'd have to be a
nutritionist to tell you
but i will say this is the only place
you can get a garbage plate any other
plate in rochester is a copycat we
trademarked it so now it's world famous
trademarking garbage genius
[Music]
you